c'est à une déambulation milieu des
rangées de livres que le visiteur est
invité ce que tu vois quelque chose de
particulier on s'est trop tôt graphie
[Musique]
garçons témoigne un petit garçon qui se
font dans la pierre michel mangon a
parcouru l'afrique de l'est à l'ouest
pour trouver sa source d'inspiration et
ses personnages le lui rendent bien
intitulé black in blague cette
exposition magnifique et contraste joue
avec l'ombre et la lumière
c'est une ode aux peintres du clair
obscur
le caravage aucun cliché n'a été pris à
la sauvette il a il passait à peu près
20 minutes avec la personne qu'ils
étaient photographiés
on le voit d'ailleurs dans l'air dans
les photographies a toujours un esprit
une des changes par le regard on le voit
bien
cette photographie elle et elle est très
très belle elle a été choisie pour la
fiche
il ya un contraste entre le visage qui
est impassible et le le tissu le drapé
du tissu et cet enfant qui regarde qui
est dans l'antre 2 qui se voilent un peu
mais qui regarde le photographe et voilà
qui est qui et complice qui a un regard
complice avec le photographe des
sourires des regards des visages
chaque photo est travaillé comme une
toile les personnages ne scrute autant
qu il nous interroge le clair-obscur
montre autant qu'il retient tient un
fondu dans les noirs dans là on voit le
grain de la peau et c'est la fusion de
la mère et de son enfant l'enfant nous
regarde mais on ne voit rien on ne voit
aucun traits de son visage
ils nous regardent il nous observe et on
le devine black in black
l'exposition de michel mangon avoir
jusqu'à fin août à la médiathèque de
pathé